we had four five six wonderful years
you're wonderful research says not so
much it's over but it's unlikely to
continue is it a single-digit world that
gets us to doubt 20,000 I think that
that's exactly right so had we been
discussing this same topic three or four
years ago when we first published this
work the dow is at around 12,000 and it
was controversial whether or not we
could even envisaged at 20,000 within
right the foreseeable future and our
view was it's a it's very likely to
happen well within the decade now at
this point I don't think that's the
question to me the question in the next
few years is not do we hit 20,000 it's
how many times we trade through exactly
exactly and here's a beautiful chart
which shows what we did at dow 10000 as
well where we bumped along and bumped
along and what this comes down to on a
physics basis is inertial force that
comes from earnings that comes from cash
flow are you just assuming that inertial
force goes away or drifts away as we
move ever higher well i think what's
what happened over the last few years is
actually that cash flows rebounded very
strongly from the the low in 2008 and
for the first three years of the
recovery it was actually the strong
earnings that were driving the market up
because pease were if you remember
declining during that time people were
so skeptical about stocks in the last
two and a half years pease have gone
from very low to slightly above historic
norms so going forward it's going to
have to be earnings that take us the
next step of the way and we think that
that's going to be a slower process as
you suggest so returns will be much more
modest I think higher high single digits
is a good guess probably six to seven
percent is our forecast and there's
gonna be a lot more volatility and
that's not a bold forecast because in
fact volatility for the last few years
has been unusually low and that's a lot
because of central bank action
especially the Fed essentially
suppressing risk with their quantitative
easing programs now that they're
stepping back we're going to see
volatility return to normal which is a
lot higher than most people are used to
one of the things we've been seeing out
west is that companies are waiting much
later to go public all the growth is
happening in the early stages of
of investment before they actually hit
the open markets is that period when
when there was amazing growth of new
companies on a publicly traded market is
that over I don't think it's over I
think what you're describing is
definitely happening in certain areas
like tech and pharma and it and it's
happening because the money is there
yeah there's there are huge pools of
money that are eager to invest in
privates and do it do so on terms that
we think are in any case it's very
generous so why wouldn't you do that I
thought that's not forever thing the
back story to your fan distribution
vaani and vaani this goes into it you
and I have talked about before work for
our eyeballs and money brothers private
equity or bonds or whatever we're up to
here with cash the question is what
growth who do we need to see to bring us
to do or 20,000 well I think that what's
likely to happen over the next few years
is you're gonna see growth be very
moderate but continued in the United
States probably something like 2.5% GDP
growth on average plus you add a little
bit of inflation and you add some
dividend yield you get yourself to a
total return on stocks of about call it
six and a half to seven percent and
that's not that's not an extreme
forecast it's also not the only thing
that we can envisage and in fact when we
do planning for our clients we're much
more worried about the downside cases
because we think an investment plan is
only as good as it is in him with bad
markets a CEO is not going to accept
single-digit growth he's gonna have a
pressure from his board to do better
they're gonna be companies that are
gonna be high single-digit double-digit
how do you select those how do you find
those particularly on this day where we
see this to mold at Twitter and actually
we think that one of the big stories in
the next five years is going to be a
major shift from the last few which is
going back to where all you have to do
is predict that the dow is gone or the
SP we're going to be busting you you
could be just in an index fund and do
great and in fact more and more people
have been going that way i think in the
next five years we're going to see
active managers who have real conviction
and are picking winners vs losers add a
huge amount of value because the indices
are not going to be skyrocketing anymore
and distinguishing which are in fact the
right companies is going to matter bunny
had the right question about growth I
just want to follow up on that does
bernstein have
a call on what long-term economic growth
will look like in the US 10 years out
yeah so we think that there are lots of
possible scenarios and we want to make
sure that our plans work even if things
that are bad that we don't expect are
likely happen but we think the most
likely scenario is that we'll see growth
of about two and a half percent and
here's the reason why population growth
in the u.s. is actually pretty good
almost one percent and that provides
some inertia some some tailwind for us
which most other countries now do not
have on top of that we think
productivity is likely to continue to
grow as well this is a big debate
including internally but our best guess
is you're going to see productivity
growth of somewhere around to program
that's a big call that's interesting